but we have to end off on this very  heartwarming video from country  superstar duo dan and shea who may have  found a third member of their group yeah  the duo spotted a young fan in the crowd  named kyler who was holding up a sign  that read i should probably go to bed  but i've waited fourteen thousand hours  for my first concert so leave it to dan  and shay to invite kyler onto the stage  and join them in singing their latest  hit so take it away guys bye morgan  when we get to the girls i should  probably go to bed  the entire crowd is gonna sing it with  you they're gonna be very loud it's  gonna be really awesome it's gonna feel  really cool  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  is  [Music]  is  yes  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you